home it's decision day in california to
determine if governor gavin newsom will
keep his job the polls close just a few
hours from now and democrats are pulling
out all the stops it's unbelievable what
happened in the final few weeks
president biden trying to make the
recall all about trump instead of
newsome's job performance
all of you know the last year i got to
run against the real donald trump
this year
this year the leading republican running
for governor
is a uh the closest thing
to a trump
clone that i've ever seen in your state
you either keep gavin newsom as your
governor
or you'll get donald trump
all right that was inspiring and newsome
continuing to push race-based attacks
against the leading republican candidate
larry elder i'll stop now
the issue of diversity of pluralism
the issue
that
defines so much of our politics that's
all on the ballot tomorrow night
racial justice is on the ballot tomorrow
night
man he's looked nervous unsure of
himself through this whole recall he
called out the president the vice
president the speaker of the house
senator elizabeth warren and needed 70
million dollars dana does that show he's
nervous or is democrats saying we're
going to win big and we all want credit
for it oh i think in the last i think
maybe like five to six weeks ago i think
they were very nervous especially as
larry elder started to pick up some
steam you know he larry elder already
has statewide name id somebody like the
mayor of san diego kevin faulkner is
very good mayor but statewide name id is
hard to get
but because larry elder had it and he's
very popular and he was talking about
the issues he didn't talk about donald
trump or biden or kamala harris he was
talking about homelessness
crime
education and the economy and he was
worried that people in california were
wanting to leave and when you when any
time that i saw gavin newsom get out
there and try to campaign he one didn't
seem authentic he sounded very angry he
didn't seem like like him he wasn't
talking about the issues and they so
badly want to run against president
trump that that's a little bit of a tell
for the 2022 midterms the other thing is
if you're the commander-in-chief and
you've left americans stranded behind
enemy lines in
afghanistan i'd spend all my time
focused on that
i wouldn't go to california i wouldn't
campaign i would make sure that
everybody knows i'm gonna make sure i'm
gonna get those people out why did he
jesse why did he show up he's
campaigning in the middle of a pandemic
he wouldn't care
trump is now the wedge issue for
democrats this is what they've done
so you're either a trump republican and
that fires up the democrat base or if
you try to distance yourself from trump
the republican base goes crazy and hates
you so that could work in a state like
california where republicans are
outnumbered but that's not really going
to play in swing districts next fall
it's a lazy argument but the real issue
is immigration has killed the republican
party in the state of california the
foreign-born population in the state of
california is 25 percent foreign-born
voters vote 2-1 democrats you do amnesty
you do those special visas
green cards
chain migration birthright amnesty
you're just loading it up we already
know hispanics vote two to one democrat
asians two to one democrat we know
blacks ninety percent they vote democrat
so in a state like that if you throw out
a lot of nasty racial attacks
to that population that's you know we're
not all paying attention that much to
politics that's going to move the needle
and then you add the 70 million dollars
in advertising and the guys good looking
gavin newsom great head of hair
charisma well tanned a lot of people pay
attention to that kind of stuff i don't
personally ever at all but a lot of
people do very similar uh hairstyle to
pete hegsett yeah both tuesdays out of
jail for more on that let's go to
jessica jessica why did they not bring
up things that he did well why don't
they say he's done a great job building
up the homeless population raising taxes
why didn't they point out some of the
things that he did well how come they're
always just saying you don't want donald
trump
you don't want donald trump or you do
want donald trump is the most animating
issue in america and continues to be
that way that that is just not going to
change even through
the midterms and jesse is right not
about the hair thing and i mean he gavin
newsom is very good-looking
but that does not
get you
a governorship
but coming out right now and saying that
it's very done well
what is news from done well besides
that's what i was hoping what has he
done well it's a great choice in
restaurants
right the french laundry is lovely right
i did not go during the pandemic besides
the french laundry what has he done well
people in the state he had a very high
approval rating what has he done well
justin
talking about like
my sister what do you want me what do
you want me to answer the question
can i just say something about who's
voting in contrast to what jesse was
saying yes you have a latino population
that tends to vote democrat that is
shifting you also have a very
conservative asian population that sent
more asian representatives on the
republican side to congress in 2020
those things make a difference they will
not shift the recall but democrats are
very aware of a shifting tide in terms
of how minority populations are voting
and he's bringing up racial justice
issues not to say that larry elder is a
white supremacist but to say that only
one party the democratic party is the
one paying attention to racial
inequality issues and one big one big
advantage he had the media on his side i
mean for them to not have the white
woman with the gorilla mask throwing
eggs at him on the front page of the l.a
times or even in the news story they
called it a an egg throwing incident
right
and then the l.a times uh viciously used
a photo of larry elder in a moment where
he was moving towards someone he knows
it looked like he was hitting her
on this story like this and said that he
had to leave this homeless encampment
because there was an incident with larry
elder implying that he was the one who
was engaged in violence against this
woman when really he was being attacked
by a white woman in a gorilla
face um but i will say it's been a long
time since ronald reagan was governor of
california
but conservatives have been making some
making up some ground in these more
conservative districts and i think that
people in california including
minorities care a lot about crime and
homelessness affecting their communities
and the places that they live and it's
interesting to me to to ask the question
to someone like gavin newsom or
president joe biden um are all the
democrats who are voting against gavin
newsom are they donald trump or all the
democrats running against gavin newsom
the same thing as donald trump because
it's not just republicans and larry
elder who want to recall the governor
there are also a lot of independents and
democrats who want to do the same thing
right uh that's why all i had to do is
say katie what do you think i didn't
even have to ask a question thank you so
much all right hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else